how could they
make a judgment how could they not come
to that conclusion they had sat
in those seats
and heard through over three weeks
of non-stop relentless testimony amber
heard tears up in her first interview
after losing johnny depp's defamation
case against her amber says she doesn't
blame the jury for the verdict which
ruled in johnny's favor
i don't blame them i actually understand
he's a beloved character
and people feel they know him he's a
fantastic actor
in a new teaser amber sits down with
nbc's savannah guthrie and shares how
she feels about the outcome of the trial
against her ex-husband mr foreperson is
this the verdict of the jury
all right is it unanimous
thank you sir a rep for amber tells et
her latest interview is a response to
johnny and his legal team speaking out
last week johnny on social media his
lawyers on tv quote miss heard simply
intended to respond to what they
aggressively did last week she did so by
expressing her thoughts and feelings
much of which she was not allowed to do
on the witness stand i don't care what
one thinks about me
or what judgments you want to make about
what happened in the privacy of my own
home and my marriage behind closed doors
so i don't take it personally but even
somebody who is
sure i'm deserving
of
all this hate and vitriol
even if you think
that i'm lying you still couldn't look
me in the eye and tell me that you think
on social media there's been a fair
representation since the jury found that
amber did in fact defame johnny her team
has been outspoken about the message it
sends to others saying in interviews
women's rights are moving backwards but
johnny's team has refuted claims that
social media played a part in his
victory
he promised you he would never you would
never see his eyes again isn't that true
you had all of the seven million dollars
for 13 months before mr depp sued you
and you chose not to pay it to the
charities who was the real monster in
this relationship ms hurd
lives in johnny half of johnny while
johnny has yet to do any on-camera
interviews his lawyer camille vazquez
sat down with savannah last week i was
speaking with another friend of ours a
mutual friend of johnny's and ours and
he said i haven't seen johnny smile like
that in six years the weight of the
world is off of his shoulders she's got
his life back as for amber's next move
according to her legal counsel the 36
year old actress is planning on
appealing the verdict and we'll hear
more from amber in her full sit-down on
tuesday and wednesday on the today show
then friday on dateline you cannot tell
me
that you think that this has been fair
you